memories are fragile  i want us to sketch out the right man we  just need enough details for someone who  knows it  it won't work no one knows him  [Music]  anchored this morning city workers found  a body from a young woman called julia  [Music]  six years ago i was cut up like her  what someone did to julia they tried it  into you  if you trained to be a reporter  then this is your story  after what he did things aren't how they  should be  it starts with little things  and then big things  and nobody remembers anything different  there are multiple women dead over  multiple decades  he's the one connecting them  there'll be more  i don't know how but he's been watching  me  since i was a kid  he's everybody  he's nobody  he's all the time  just because something hasn't happened  doesn't mean it won't  work all connected  things change for me just  like that  and then it happens again  and again  and again  you shouldn't be here  what's his name  the man who visits you  [Music]  you